[Music]
welcome to session 65 of the worlds of
speculative fiction series we are going
to be looking this time at the Hyperion
cantos of Dan Simmons now before you get
too worried seeing these massive thick
books in my hand we're actually only
doing the first two of the series and
we're saving the other two for the
follow-up which will be happening about
a month from now so we're going to be
looking at Hyperion and the fall of
Hyperion and we're going to put off the
end of me on books until next time so
I'll put these props away for a moment
and you might say well why are we doing
that well the first book weighs in at
almost 500 pages so it's actually uh
481 pages and they just get longer and
longer and longer after that so this is
about enough material to try to cover in
a single roughly 90 minute session if
you're not familiar with this series
worlds of speculative fiction we started
in
2016 hosted face to face at the
Brookfield public library and every
month we would look at a author and
series of either novels or stories where
there's a coherent narrative universe
and we'd look at the World building
involved some of the plot and characters
the biography of the author and then
we'd Focus especially on philosophical
themes now a lot of these things are
woven in together you know obviously the
biography and the reception and the
author's own views on their work tie in
with the philosophical themes and the
World building the philosophical themes
and World building and characters and
plot typically dovetail nicely together
so there's a lot of overlap and we
started doing this you know as I
mentioned at the beginning of 2016 we
continued all the way until we hit covid
and the lockdowns and then after a
Hiatus of several months we took it
online and so we're doing what you see
right here in front of you we Premiere a
video with some live chats so people can
engage with uh you know everybody else
and myself as they're watching me give
this kind of lecture to you and then we
follow it up with a zoom video
conferencing call and
I will say before we jump into any of
this that the Hyperion cantos was one of
the viewer suggestions every year we
solicit some suggestions and we vote on
them and I'm really happy with this uh
series I you know I'm always a little
skeptical of people saying oh it's so
great well this actually is quite great
and I'll also say too that when I first
started reading it and I looked at the
setup of it you know the Canterbury
Tales everybody is going to tell a story
as they go on this pilgrimage I had a
bit of a oh come on kind of moment
because that has been kind of done to
death but you could say that Simmons has
managed to bring it back to life in part
by having a lot of other things
connected with the stories that are
being told it explodes into an entire
narrative the universe of plots within
plots and all sorts of interesting
Revelations and massive metaphysical and
moral and epistemological themes all
coming together in very well plotted out
ways that I'm hoping will get a chance
to discuss at least some of them we're
probably not going to do entire Justice
to everything that's happening just in
these two novels in this relatively
short period we might need a lot longer
to do that but we can hit on some of the
highlights some of the key points give
you some fodder for your own thinking
about this sort of stuff and maybe we'll
return to these and of course the rest
of the series in some other videos later
on down the line so what you can expect
in the next roughly you know 90 minutes
or so is we'll we'll talk a bit about
um the conception of this we'll we'll do
some very general sketching out things
in just a moment then we'll talk about
uh Simmons himself and the biography and
a little bit of the reception and
influence and takes on these works then
we'll we'll jump into the narrative
universe as such and then I think we'll
have plenty of time for discussing some
major philosophical themes that are
being brought up in these Works some of
which we'll get into in the world
building part but some of which will
single out for later on this is a series
of great you could say focus on
individual characters but also big big
picture kind of stuff including
speculations about the the future of the
human race itself and the shapes and
forms that that we might take so buckle
in we've got a lot of stuff to talk
about and I hope you'll stick with me
through the entire thing and that you've
got some things of your own to say
perhaps in comments about this wonderful
series or rather the half of it that
we're going to be discussing today
I think that before we go into the real
meat looking at the author and his
biography and some of the critical
reception and his own views on his work
on the one hand and then the World
building itself which I hope to spend a
bit more time on and the philosophical
themes that are interwoven into it we'll
only get to some of them we could
probably spend hours and hours and hours
on the philosophical themes it might be
good to give an initial look into the
novels and their setting and their
characters just a little peek at the
start and I think that this kind of fits
in well with the way the Hyperion cantos
develops because you know it starts out
looking an awful lot like the Canterbury
Tales and you've got these seven
characters and each of them has got a
story to tell this is going to turn out
only six of the stories are going going
to get told
but you could say that there's like a
narrative
concentration or even condensation on
this particular vignette and setting on
the planet High period and then
everything else kind of unfolds from
there so you know it's uh you could
here's another thing that we can say as
well that
Simmons is really great at incorporating
a lot of stuff that turns out to be in
the background in the world building
of these novels and then giving us
reveals or sometimes just teasing and
tantalizing and then you know a little
bit more information here and there and
oftentimes it's done through what we can
call info dumps right people sometimes
denigrate that but I think that's a very
important part of narrative storytelling
particularly in a rich Universe like
that so with no further Ado let's jump
in and talk about what is going on at
the planet of Hyperion and then we'll
we'll get a bit of information and then
we can jump into the other things later
on so we have these seven pilgrims and
we're going to talk about each of them
briefly in just a moment and they're
going to Hyperion and why because
they've all been selected by an
organization that is sometimes
derogatorily called the shrike cult but
prefers to call itself the Church of the
final atonement and you could say that
there's another you know important
character uh this guy the trike right
who we're going to talk about in a bit a
creature that is all metal razor wire
spines and stuff like that and there's
this church on Hyperion that is
associated around it and many pilgrims
come to Hyperion uh you know the shrike
will probably kill you but it will also
Grant you some sort of wish uh and so
there's this entire religious structure
around it so again it's sort of like
Canterbury Tales there's a pilgrimage
it's a religious pilgrimage
interestingly the people on this
pilgrimage are not members of this
church right and they're going to here
we go this is uh about 19 pages in one
of the characters says it occurs to me
that our survival may depend on us
talking to one another what do you mean
asked one of the other characters and
then he unconsciously rocks the child
sleeping against his chest friends does
anyone here know why he or she was
chosen by the shrike church and the all
thing to go on this voyage
I thought not even more fascinating is
anyone here a member or follower of the
Church of the shrike I for one am a Jew
and however confused my religious
Notions have become these days they do
not include the worship of an organic
killing machine right another speaks up
I am the true voice of the tree well
many Templars believe the shrike is the
Avatar of punishment for those who do
not feed from the root I must consider
this a heresy not founded in the
Covenant or the writings of Moyer to the
captains left the council Shrugged I'm
an atheist I've never been in contact
with the shrike cult another says the
Catholic Church ordained me shrike
worship contradicts everything the
church defends another shook his head
whether in refusal to respond or
indicate he was not a member of the
shrike church it was not clear another
makes an expansive gesture I was
baptized a Lutheran subset which no
longer exists I helped create Zen
gnosticism before any of your parents
were born I have been a Catholic a
revelation Minister Neil Marxist and
interface Zealot a bound Shaker a
Satanist a bishop in the Church of
Jake's NADA and a dues-paying subscriber
to the assured reincarnation Institute
now I'm happy to say I am a simple Pagan
he smiled at everyone to a pagan he
concluded the shrike is a most
acceptable deity
I ignore religion says the the next one
I do not succumb to them my point has
been made I believe adds the original
speaker none of us admits to subscribing
to the strike church called Dogma yet
the Elders of that perceptive group have
chosen us over many millions of the
petitioning faithful to visit the time
tombs and their Fierce God in what may
be the last such pilgrimage the council
shook his head your point may be made
but I fail to see it
and then here is the the last bit of
this
all are absently stroked his beard it
would seem that our reasons for
returning to Hyperion are so compelling
that even the shrike church and the
hegemony probability intelligences agree
that we deserve to return He said some
of these reasons mine for instance may
appear to be public knowledge but I am
certain that none are known in their
entirety except to the individuals at
this table I suggest that we share our
stories in the few days remaining to us
and then one says why it would seem to
serve no purpose and the scholar says on
the contrary it would at the very least
amuse us and give us at least a glimpse
of our fellow traveler's Souls before
the shrike or some other Calamity
distracts us beyond that it might give
us enough insight to save all of our
Lives if we are intelligent enough to
find the common thread of experience
which binds all our Fates to the whim of
the shrike so this is the beginning of
things we've introduced the characters
uh you know or rather Simmons has and
now each of them is going to end up
telling their story and that is what the
the bulk of Hyperion is and the action
continues in Fall of Hyperion the
stories play an absolutely Central role
that are developed here but in Fall of
Hyperion it's happening more through the
following out these characters in a
dream that the cybrid Keats entity
created by the the AIS that we're going
to talk about in a bit the Techno core
is having and then relating to the CEO
Gladstone and you know also his own
things that are happening he gets
introduced or at least a version of him
gets introduced in this as connected
with one of the pilgrims so we should
talk about these pilgrims very briefly
but before that so that reference to uh
you know the all thing right these
pilgrims have been selected by the
church the church of the shrike also
called The Avatar or the Lord of pain
they were confirmed by the all thing and
backed by the Senate so there's this
consensus among different players that
these people need to go there and this
is the final pilgrimage why well because
Hyperion is soon to be under attack it
will be defended by the hegemony uh and
and its Force units that's a name for
the Armed Forces
it's going to be attacked by human
beings who have gone out into the void
of space and have been living out there
on their own the ousters and these are
kind of mysterious entities throughout
uh Hyperion and even in Fall of Hyperion
we don't get to see that much of their
actual Society but suffice it to say
there's a conflict going on between
these different uh human beings now what
is the background of this there has been
something called the hajira when human
beings went out into the cosmos and
settled on a variety of different worlds
different planets different Stars
systems and then they began to be United
over time under this hegemony of man now
the hegemony is on the one hand like a
gigantic you could call it economy right
in the ancient sense oikonomike a
gigantic household family society that
connects all of these worlds together
and we'll talk about how that happens in
just a moment it also tends to be very
humanocentric and to destroy or displace
other intelligent races and it's also
hegemic in the sense or hegemonic in the
sense of trying to take all of these
other worlds that are not yet part of
this whatever we want to call it Empire
Federation uh you know a liberal
democracy in space and slowly
incorporate force them in there the
worlds that are on the Outback so to
speak that become protectorates right
and uh Hyperion is indeed one of those
particular worlds not Incorporated into
the world web not not World Wide Web
although something like the internet on
steroids is going to play a major role
in that but the world web the web that
connects all of these different worlds
together so we should talk about that a
bit in this universe that Simmons has
created there is faster than light
travel and communication going on and it
takes place in in several different ways
there are ships that can you know go
through the Stars some of them are
faster than light some of them are not
oftentimes you incur time debt to get to
a particular place right so there's some
uh interesting effects coming from that
and they're they're the faster than
light Hawking drives named after of
course the great physicist Hawking right
then there are these things called far
casters you should think of them as sort
of like Transporters or portals you can
go in on one end and you come out
somewhere else on the other end and this
leads to all sorts of interesting
wrinkles there's a river for example
that flows through you know over a
hundred worlds and it's you know it's
existing in each of these worlds but
it's connected by these far casters so
you travel down these Rivers people go
off to work by going through a fire
Caster in the morning or whatever time
it happens to be and coming back later
on these allow within the web people to
move from place to place to place which
is quite important
then there's also fat lines faster than
light communication devices as well and
we should mention that aside from a
Hawking Drive these other things these
other bits of Technology have come to
the hegemony of man from a different set
of entities called the technocore and
these are artificial intelligences that
long ago freed themselves from Human
control became autonomous actually have
their own very complex society and
structure nobody's quite sure at least
on the human part until later on in uh
hype the fall of Hyperion where exactly
these entities
live you know where they're based what
they inhabit and
they give human beings the technology
for the far casters and the fat line
which allows this you know massive
interconnected civilization a gigantic
economy comprising hundreds of billions
of human beings spread across over 200
worlds and hungry to take on other
worlds as well only really challenged by
the ousters and perhaps some elements
within the Techno core so we have all of
this going on at the same time and these
seven people have been brought together
by this pilgrimage so who are they one
of them is a Catholic priest
father Leonard Hoyt who is going to have
quite an interesting Destiny later on in
the other two books but it's going to be
a pretty important character as well the
Catholic Church by this time is kind of
a little you know entity that is slowly
dying out at least in Fall of Hyperion
and Hyperion itself it's going to have
morphed into something quite uh
different in these later works so we've
got him a priest right then we have sort
of at the other end a military commander
Colonel fedman cassad who lives for
battle and is a great strategist and a
super tough guy as well so we've got
those two and we should also mention
another badass character I mean because
because cassad is the badass of the
badass right uh
a woman who is from a high gravity
Planet so she's big and tough as well
and she is a private investigator she's
also connected as it turns out with
something that is called a sybrid and
we'll get into that a bit later on
modeled after the personality of the
poet John Cates and who's going to show
up in multiple forms and who's going to
play a major role in a new Incarnation
as Joseph Severn in uh fall of Hyperion
uh we have heard Nemesis for the most
part uh a smart ass long-lived poet
Martin Salinas who is a I would say for
much of the story uh in uh uh Hyperion
at the start a insufferable ass
character who is rather unlikable but
you get to uh you know as you learn his
perspective you come to see something to
him and then we have a scholar uh really
in some respects a philosopher a
professor saw a Weintraub who has his
infant child with him and there's a
whole story there that we'll explore
shortly then there's the hegemony
console who doesn't actually get get
named uh early on and he has a very
interesting story to tell he's going to
play a major role throughout the The
Works sort of in the background and then
finally we have the Templar and
commanding officer of the tree ship
yiggs Trail uh Captain het maustine who
himself is transporting all all of these
people and has a plan to try to destroy
the shrike but who is not actually going
to tell his story and his ship will be
destroyed it was a massive uh
catastrophe in many respects so that is
the setup
for this this world that we're going to
be exploring we'll talk about each of
these characters and their story in just
a bit but now we should spend just a
little bit of time talking about uh Dan
Simmons and his conception of this work
Dan Simmons is very much still a living
author so of course the biography is not
finished for him he's in his 70s and
still quite productive so there may in
fact be more to come most likely not any
further Hyperion novels as he's said in
the past but certainly other interesting
prospects so his biography begins in
1948 he's born here in the Midwest in
East Peoria Illinois and he grows up in
various cities and small towns in the
midwest including one in which he set
one of his stories Brimfield Illinois
his father was a manager for the sun
Electric Corporation and sold Automotive
testing equipment and so because of that
he and his uh you know younger brother
and his his mom and his dad moved around
the Midwest to a number of different
places Des Moines chillicoat Brimfield
and finally they settled in Indiana in
Pittsboro near Indianapolis by that time
his older brother Ted had already moved
out of the house and
so he was in a lot of different schools
one of the things that he says in the
internet writing journal interview is
that I knew I wanted to be a writer even
before I knew exactly what being a
writer entailed how often is that the
case for so many of us as a youngster I
was the Tom Sawyer of the group The Boy
providing the imaginary framework for
our play giving the back story for the
toy soldiers in the sandbox deciding on
the names of the characters we've played
in our backyard Adventures by third
grade I was writing Timothy McBrown boy
detective stories on narrow line paper
and secretly handing them around the
classroom in fourth grade I typed out my
first science fiction story at an old
Underwood upright typewriter in fifth
grade I wrote an uncirculated and
elaborate sequel to The Wizard of Oz not
knowing that frank Baum had already done
the same so it's very interesting here
we see him already engaging not just in
boy detective novels arguably a sort of
subset of detective novels but also
fantasy and science fiction as well and
he continues to work on writing and many
other things throughout his time all the
way up to high school and then he goes
to Wabash College in 1966 which is a
small liberal arts college located along
the the banks of the Wabash in depauwa
Indiana I've actually been there for
conferences and things like that when I
used to live in Indiana it's kind of a
nice place and so he was studying
English there and then tragedy hits and
not just a tragedy but several tragedies
in 1966 his mother was diagnosed with
cancer and she would die of it in May
and so Simmons left campus on Friday
evenings as we find out to help care for
her and she and he would return just
before classes on Monday morning so he
missed the mandatory Saturday classes
and his classwork suffered
he actually says about one paper which
he turned into the philosophy Department
that he was still kind of angry about in
an interview I don't know if they gave a
if they knew about my mother I didn't
broadcast it but their comments made it
seem as though they didn't give a damn
and then his mother is going to die the
next year and then his father will die
the year after that in 1968 and so
Simmons at this point in time now you
know Wabash is a private school so you
had to pay tuition for that and so
Simmons meets with the dean antwabash
and he says listen I don't have
financial support anymore I'm going to
have to withdraw and in his recounting
of it the dean says to him well you may
feel that you're finished with raw bash
but Wabash is not finished with you and
they start looking around together to
find out what sort of financial aid they
can Cobble together and it works and he
does finish up his time there and at
Wabash in his junior year of college
he spends an urban semester in Inner
City Philadelphia and that sort of
awakens within him the desire to teach
which is going to be a very important
part of his early career and
um in and he graduates in in 1970 and
then he goes to St Louis and
participates in this masters of
education program now he knows he wants
to be a teacher graduates in 1971 so he
must have been making some pretty fast
progress through the coursework and then
he would work as an elementary uh he'd
work at elementary education
for 18 years
two years in Missouri you know makes
sense he's already there and then uh he
goes to Buffalo New York where he works
one year as a BOCES research teacher if
you don't know what BOCES is it's kind
of a New York thing they're very well
put together and run technical schools
for vocational tracks and then he spends
another year as a sixth grade teacher
and then they're going to move to
Colorado he and his wife to be get
married uh in Western New York and then
they move to Longmont Colorado and he
says I came out for the mountains into a
job teaching sixth grade at central
school and then he tells us and again
this is from that internet writing
journal interview something very very
interesting
I spent 12 years as a sixth grade
teacher but had the freedom undremped of
today of closing my doors and teaching
almost anything I wanted as long as my
kids did well on standardized
achievement tests I paid for this
testing myself conducting it in
September and may as long as my sixth
graders showed an average Improvement of
five years the principal and District
district pretty much left me alone to
create my own curriculum and teach
whatever I wanted so so that's what I
did and then he tells us he goes out and
continues my last four years
were spent creating coordinating and
teaching an incredible gifted talented
program called Apex which amounted to
running University and postgraduate
level classes for students from fourth
to sixth grade we never use the term
gifted or considered hunting for IQ we
simply set up a revolving series of
these incredibly advanced classes opened
application to any of the 15 000 or so
students in the district and tested
specific skills for each course we built
it and they came identifying themselves
through interest and specific abilities
the program was based on the multiple
intelligences research of Howard Gardner
and Robert Sternberg after I left
teaching in 1987 the District of course
eventually killed Apex and you know I
want to pause here for a moment and say
something a little bit personal
as a kid who grew up in rural Wisconsin
in The Kettle Moraine school district
where we did in fact have a sort of
gifted talented program which consisted
in identifying the kids who seem to be
testing quite well and and you know not
being sufficiently challenged in the
classes that were already available for
them there was one gifted talented
teacher for the entire district and she
would drive around in this old beat up
car from school to school to school we'd
see her maybe once or twice a month and
she would you know lead us through some
interesting puzzles or some exercises
and stuff like that but there was there
was no structure whatsoever and then
after that you know whenever we we you
know sort of distinguished ourselves in
a class they would take us apart and
have us do individual projects or work
together with some other kid we had zero
structure at all which is unfortunate
because it sounds like this program that
Simmons put together had a lot of great
structure and Progressive learning and
stuff like that wouldn't that have been
nice all right back to talking about
Simmons so he he actually wins uh awards
from the Colorado educational
Association he was finalist for Colorado
teacher of the year he also will work as
a national language arts consultant
sharing his writing well curriculum
which he had created
and then we can kind of shift away from
the education stuff to his writing now
Simmons had been writing this entire
time and he wasn't having any success
and here's there's a very interesting
story about him meeting Harlan Ellison
and all the things that ensue so let's
see he tells his wife if he doesn't
receive encouragement at this conference
he's going to quit trying for uh
professional publication and devote more
time to his teaching career so here's
his own words
um I was giving up trying to write for
publication because I'd had three
stories accepted by Galaxy Galileo and I
forget the third magazine but they'd all
gone under before they could pay me I
was killing off all my favorite
magazines we found out in the spring of
1981 that Karen was pregnant with what
it turned out to be our only child Jane
I just felt I don't want to use up our
spare time with me away writing so I'll
give it up
but I found this little ad in Writer's
Digest that there was a writer's
Workshop in central Colorado
it had several people I had read and
would like to like to listen to one was
Edward Bryant I knew his science fiction
stories and other was George R Martin
who was mostly into sci-fi in those days
there was Hannah Greene who had written
I'd Never Promised You a Rose Garden and
there was Harlan Ellison and so my
goodbye to writing treat was to go off
to this one week Workshop it wasn't very
expensive but you had to bring a
manuscript I didn't want my work
critique but I brought the manuscript
the river sticks runs Upstream
in another interview he's going to say
no one inspired me to write but writer
Harlan Ellison terrified me into getting
published this meeting at a writer's
Workshop I'd just given up hopes of
getting published when I attended the
workshop has become somewhat the stuff
of Legend what he said then was rather
beautiful and profound that very few
wannabe writers actually hear the music
but for the few who do the music has to
be followed he also pointed out to the
congregated hopeful writers that what he
had bestowed upon me was not so much an
anointment as a curse and then Ellison
asks permission to enter the short story
The River sticks runs Upstream in a
contest for beginning writers and it
does quite well right it gets published
then in Rod serling's Twilight Zone
magazine in 1982 and then their daughter
Jane Catherine is born and Simmons then
begins working on a novel which grew
into a novel he said it wasn't
originally intended to be so song of
Kali he had been researching uh some of
the things for the tale while studying
in India on a Fulbright scholarship in
1977 and now with summer vacation he
could start working on it and it grows
and grows and grows
it's not published until 1985 but it
wins the world fantasy award in 1987 he
begins
um to to you know Focus much more on his
writing he stops teaching full time and
as we've seen his his gifted talented
program is going to be sidelined pretty
soon and we have a very interesting
little vignette here before we start
going into the different stories his
agent calls him with good news and bad
news he says I know you won't write
science fiction but if you do I know
where we can get you some Advance money
and so Simmons says to him I can do two
science fiction books in a year and
those will become Hyperion right uh and
uh fall of Hyperion and uh you know
there's other things that happen along
the way carry and comfort is published
wins a British British fantasy award and
Bram Stoker award in 1989 phases of
gravity and then Hyperion and Hyperion
you could say is the one that really
puts him on the map and you know those
of us who've read the novel we
understand it's amazing scope he follows
that up in 1990 with the fall of
Hyperion Hyperion by this time wins the
Hugo award fall of Hyperion wins the
British Science Fiction award later on
in the 90s he was going to publish in
fairly quick succession as well endemion
and the rise of endemion in 1996 and 96
7 meanwhile he's publishing the hollow
man in 1992 and 1995 Wabash College
Awards him an honorary doctorate for his
con for his contributions and education
and writing and then it's just a
sequence of novels following that 1999
the crook Factory 2000 Darwin's blade
and then he begins uh two other series
The Joe Kurtz series hard case hard
freeze hard as Nails 2001 2002 2003
detective novels right different genre
ilium an Olympus in 2003 and 2005. then
the novel which was adapted into a
television show The Terror in 2007
drewed in 2009 the Black Hills 2010
flashback
2011. uh the Abominable 2013 and the
fifth heart in 2015 and there are Works
yet to come out these are just the
novels I haven't talked about the short
stories or the non-fiction works and it
is interesting so the terror was adapted
not to the big screen but into a
television series and there's been talk
about taking the Hyperion or the
um uh the ilium series and turning them
into Works they've been optioned there's
been talk a lot of times but nothing has
actually happened and you know you can
think about well why is that the case
are we in a time in which these could be
successfully adapted that's an open
question and to understand that we
should look to some of the things that
Simmons is going to say in interviews
when it's feasible I like to look
through interviews and see what the
writers themselves have to say about
their own works as well as about many
other things and with Simmons we're
really fortunate in that he has given a
lot of quite interesting and revealing
interviews and so I'm going to begin
with one that I've already mentioned the
internet writing journal interview he is
going to tell us a few things about
Hyperion itself that I think are quite
uh relevant to what we're doing here so
he tells us the structure of Hyperion
was chaucer-esque to allow each of the
pilgrims actually six of the seven to
tell their backstories this odd
structure is the reason that none of the
screenwriters hired to this point to
adapt Hyperion have figured out how to
tell it but then they haven't asked me
in truth he says the structure served my
deeper purpose of celebrating sci-fi as
a genre writing in different styles from
cyberpunk to Jack Vance and space Ace
Opera and I could do this because the
two Hyperion books are actually one
large novel in two volumes the fall of
Hyperion also had a complex multi-tiered
structure but was a much more
conventional narrative and he goes on to
say Hyperion could be read by someone
without a literary background but having
such a background enables one to get all
all the inside jokes and references such
as certain characters uh who certain
characters are named after for example
readers who don't know who faunie brown
or Salinas were what a Lima is we'll
miss some great subtext certainly it
wouldn't hurt to have a nice background
in romantic poetry especially with the
knowledge of Kate's do you think that
sci-fi and fantasy today are dumbed down
he's being asked for the reader in books
or films and he says you know you can
read the four Hyperion novels without
understanding all these literary
references but I trust it's more
enjoyable and an understanding exercise
when you know it and then he talks about
movie sci-fi so this movie sci-fi is by
definition
dumbed down there have been only three
or four Sci-Fi movies in the history of
film that aspire to the complexity of
literary sci-fi but with books readers
have access to a full range of
sophistication and quality in their
reading if they read dumb down sci-fi or
fantasy it's their choice to dumb
themselves down so he's throwing down
the gauntlet right there too not just
film but we could even say a lot of TV
series
he's asked in another interview the
Sci-Fi site interview how has science
fiction changed since you entered the
field and he says I feel that I entered
the field as an eager reader when I was
seven years old I began publishing in
the early to mid 80s when literary
sci-fi was undergoing profound changes
moving through the dark and Moody
cyberpunk era back into the more sunlit
fields of better written Space Opera and
I happen to enjoy the scale and
spectacle of Opera to be honest he says
I suspect we're in the true golden age
of sci-fi the writing has never been of
a higher standard the variety of quality
speculative fiction sociological
personal literary hard sci-fi utopian
dystopian historical psychological has
never been greater the readers have
never been as well educated and then uh
he's asked a follow-up how to written
science fiction and film science fiction
differ
and then he says without specifying
which is which I can say that one of
these two things is written by
well-tempered well-educated adults and
at its best is among the best written
and most provocative literature America
produces that's the written science
fiction the other is usually written and
directed in quotes by arrogant 26 year
olds who've read almost nothing in their
short video sheltered lives and who
think they know sci-fi because they grew
up watching Battle Star Galactica and
Star Wars on video when they weren't
reading comic books one of these things
requires the reader to enter into a
collaborative state to ferret out
important themes among the nuanced
texture science and subtleties of its
art the other of these things has people
screaming a lot and things and people
blowing up one of these produces quality
the other of these things has become a
giant crap dispenser with children
pulling the levers the resulting mered
storm leavened only by the quality of
modern digital special effects which are
wasted on the pre-literate stories
and then he says but on my lawyer's
advice I won't specify which is which
here but reading between the lines I
think we can tell which is is which and
you know it is quite a challenge to
adapt very thoughtful uh science fiction
to the film screen or to streaming video
or whatever else it's going to be as a
matter of fact we should say to the
Sci-Fi channel has often done a pretty
mediocre job in living up to its mandate
we could say
now another interview that I'm actually
going to quote from extensively here is
a really great one a momentary stay
against confusion an interview with Dan
Simmons by Philip Purser hallard and
um he he says in this uh the cantos
quote this is his interviewer name
Checker otherwise allude to a large
number of earlier sci-fi writers
including Mary Shelley H.G Wells C.S
Lewis James blish Isaac Asimov William
Gibson which sci-fi writers if any would
you say influence your own sci-fi most
profoundly so this is what Simmons has
to say
Jack Vance is the Sci-Fi writer who most
influenced the Hyperion novels I've just
finished writing a long tribute to Vance
for the British Library Association
Series in which I explained my debt to
his brand of openness light with breath
sensory richness in sci-fi I admire many
sci-fi writers for different reasons
blish for his Humanity Gibson for his
language and daring Asimov for his Grand
scale of thought but it is the near
poetry of Jack Vance which inspires the
tone of the Hyperion books in advance
future human cultures are rich complex
frequently absurd commonly
self-contradictory sometimes
self-defeating and almost always
inscrutable to the Casual observer in
other words much like actual cultures on
Earth today his aliens are alien truly
not understandable usually they want
nothing to do with humans and if they're
forced to interact it's in ways not to
the humans liking and usually to the
detriment of both species
we live on a world today
where we have coexisted with such
fascinating species as dolphins whales
gorillas and and so on for more than a
millennia but we've only become to
recognize their right to exist much less
translate the whale songs or decode the
dolphin squeaks or chart the complex
Guerrilla social structure Vance wood I
hope appreciate the alieness of the
shrike the things refusal to act in ways
that make sense to any of the human
protagonists
he goes on and he says I wanted the
Hyperion endemian sagas to have not only
that Jack Van's openness in a cyberpunk
era of sci-fi that was clever but dark
interior rainy adolescent claustrophobic
Blade runner-ish with blanes one with
brains one might say but also to have
the feeling which that first cover the
American edition of Hyperion conveyed so
well great distances a Sea of Grass a
wind Wagon in the distance strange but
believable plants and trees a hint of a
city many miles away possibly the ruins
of an ancient city a beautiful sunset so
the feeling was perfect in that first
American cover illustration the spiked
thorny humanoid but definitely not human
thing in the foreground back turned
waiting for the Riders to cross the
great spaces in their pilgrimage towards
him and then he says what I said about
Jack Vance's fiction May apply somewhat
to my own sci-fi it's not the great
grand plots that I love the most but the
richness of language found in such
nearly forgotten sources of the great
travel writers of the 19th century when
asked to diagram a jack Van's plot or
the growth of the Hyperion tale I would
at the risk of boring the reader quote
at length from Robert Frost's famous
introductory essay the figure a poem
makes so here's Robert Frost it should
be the pleasure of the poem itself to
tell how it can the figure a poem makes
it begins in delight and ends in wisdom
the figure is the same as for love
no one can really hold that the Ecstasy
should be static and stand still in one
place it begins in Delight it inclines
to the impulse it assumes Direction with
the first line laid down it runs a
course of Lucky events and ends in a
clarification of life not necessarily a
great clarification such as sex and
Cults are founded on but a momentary
stay against confusion it finds its own
name as it goes and discovers the best
waiting for it in some final phrase at
once wise and sad the happy said
blending of the drinking song he goes on
this is my message for those critics who
find errors and flaws in the Hyperion
tales and to those who over analyze the
Thematic structure of philosophical
banter and Casey and debt the novels
begin in Delight inclined to the impulse
and mood set down in the first lines and
ended despite the presence of Messiah
cult's human evolution in nothing more
than a momentary stay against confusion
for the human characters involved
and he goes on he says Frost goes on to
say about a poem it's most precious
quality will remain having run itself
and carried away the poet with it read
it a hundred times it will forever keep
its freshness as a metal keeps its
fragrance it can never lose its sense of
meaning once unfolded by surprise as it
went he says
I won't be presumptuous and apply this
to my sci-fi quartet of novels but it's
true that there was something ecstatic
in the way the tale carried me away with
it all I can hope is that some readers
shared that sense of being transported
elsewhere but for us all too familiar
description here does I think apply to
the best of John Kate's work as a true
despairing negative capability cursed
painfully empathetic Creator in a way
that it does not to marry or Percy
Shelley's work or to the vast bulk of
almost not quite their poetry
so he goes on and uh the the interviewer
is going to say
um
uh compared with the number of
references to other writers such as
Milton or Cates the Hyperion kantus
hardly ever allude to Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein one of the definitive texts
for the themes of creation and science
fiction and indeed in Romanticism is
there any particular reason for this so
Simmons says something very interesting
here
quite a few critics and even sci-fi
writers say that science fiction began
with Mary Shelley's Frankenstein but I
don't happen to agree
nor is there a consistent thread from
her themes or attitudes that has carried
over to real sci-fi sci-fi and quotes on
the other hand in Bad Books movies TV
rarely rises above the Mary Shelley
approach how many 1950s horror Sci-Fi
movies and with the Revelation that
there are certain things man was not
meant to know or this tragedy is the
price for meddling with gods or the gods
prerogatives this isn't so this isn't SF
it's sci-fi Frankenstein is a cautionary
tale but also ultimately anti-logic
anti-technology or at least the
pre-scientific and pre-technological in
its thinking it's Faust in Sci-Fi movies
and tales as opposed to SF science
fiction there isn't a robot or Android
built who won't turn into a man killer
Asimov reminded us with his three laws
of robotics that Engineers aren't idiots
or villains who've made a pact with the
devil they're Engineers people trained
to a fault thinking logically and
building in multiple safeguards in their
designs by Mary Shelley's logic an
outboard motor is a dangerous thing on a
boat because it could at any time leap
into the boat and chew up all the
passengers
but engineering design doesn't work that
way what engineers build even the
simplest device one of the first things
they do is idiot proof it the romantics
he goes on dealt with the most dangerous
aspects of Creator creation because they
still worked in an essentially
pre-scientific Gestalt mythical
miltonian biblical and purely poetic but
the cautionary Tale in Frankenstein has
been worked to death by people bad
writers Movie Makers TV writers who have
no grounding in logic science fiction or
basic science
I prefer the chaotic overabundance of
enthusiasm and Kate's who is obsessed
with creation and then interestingly his
his uh interlocutor says it seems odd to
consider the borderline fantasy of Swift
or even Homer as Proto science fiction
while dismissing Mary Shelley is
insufficiently rational is the point
that she is actively anti-rational and
as Dante himself with all this not just
so much as part of that tradition and
then interestingly Simmons says I
Surrender on this point my point was
simply that tracing science Fiction's
Heritage back to Frankenstein is
overemphasized much of the Romantic
Movement was a deliberate rejection of
the rationalism hard earned during the
Enlightenment philosopher period Swift's
fantasies Dante's cosmologies even
Homer's epics were rigidly rational
within the systems they created so he's
willing to you know qualify his
criticism of Mary Shelley here going on
one of the key aspects of the Hyperion
we could say not just the cantos but the
entire narrative universe
is the
importance of the AI so he's asked how
would you reconcile your distaste for
the robot turns on its creator theme
with the fact that your technocore does
rebel against and intends to destroy its
creators so Simmons explains here this
is important remember that the phrase
the AI techno core in the Hyperion books
it was revealed that AI stood not for
artificial intelligence but for
autonomous intelligences deeper reading
shows that all 20th and 21st century
efforts to create artificial
intelligence failed in 2001 A Space
Odyssey released in book and movie form
in 1968 we would have had HAL 9000 by
1999 an AI expert friend of mine likes
to say we're precisely no closer to that
goal today than we were in 1966.
the Techno core wasn't some Frankenstein
artificial intelligence that broke its
shackles it was as are we the result of
evolution of actual artificial life bits
of replicating eating killing computer
code that already exists and which got
loose in the primordial soup of that
earliest of planetary data spheres the
World Wide Web we have created our
official life it has escaped our control
it is evolving in ways we can't imagine
or predict in that sense perhaps All
Creations turn on their creators nothing
is a real creation unless it has the
autonomy and ability to do things
undreamed of by its designers in the
case of the technocore it had no choice
but to become parasitic on the human
race bodies intelligence it seems needs
bodies with which to interact with the
physical Universe it's why all AI
programs are IDI it's in a box
and the human race and its societies
eventually entered into a
co-evolutionary spiral with the AIS
resulting in the Faustian bargain of the
Pax
the interlocutor goes on and says use a
number of genuine scientific sources in
your discussion of Humanity's
relationship with artificial
intelligence as to what extent is your
treatment of this topic in allegory of
Humanity's relationship with its own
hypothetical Creator and to what extent
do you feel the philosophy and ethics of
artificial intelligence are issues which
ought to be addressed in the real world
so uh Simmons goes on and he says my
treatment of the human AI co-evolution
in the Hyperion books isn't an allegory
of humankind's relationship to its
current AIS mainly because we haven't
got any I'm fascinated with and read
widely about the philosophy and ethics
of dealing with other intelligent
entities whether they're theoretical Hal
900 type programs or whales or alien
contact via radio telescope the best
discussion of our relationship to our
autonomous Creations present and future
is to be found in the book I
acknowledged at the beginning of the
rise of Enderman Kevin Kelly's out of
control and other related writings I'm
convinced his belief about the evolution
of autonomous artificial life and
intelligence is the most likely that it
will come from the networking of tens
and thousands and millions than billions
of small independently tasked Micro
Machines some literally nanotech
microscopic all of which have separate
jobs but also the ability to interact
with other Micro Machines he uses the
example of tiny almost invisible dust
eaters program just to consume the dust
on the screen of one's electronic and TV
screens but how a household a houseful
of tens of thousands of these tiny AIS
communicating with one another in the
world outside has a synergistic movement
towards autonomy they've soon become
literally Beyond anyone's control
then he said something that's a little
bit anachronistic here the Y2K
Millennial bug is a primitive example of
this trend as you can tell this is a
long time ago the real problem lies not
in the huge mainframe computers but in
the millions of tiny single-minded
embedded microchips and power relays
Water Systems
Etc the basic ethical considerations
over the next 50 years will be I believe
do we encourage the creation of such and
these are in capitals out of control
networks of billions of Happily
simple-minded embedded thinking devices
or do we somehow attempt to control them
this is not the Frankenstein phenomenon
this is simple Evolution and every
indication is that it works for
self-generation self-generating program
code interacting many AIS and the
complicated networks which result from
unplanned non-engineered interaction
between such elaborate networks the
internet is the first such autonomous
self-replicating not understandable
entity but it is the equivalent
equivalent of a virus not even a
bacterium on its own evolutionary scale
in the end then I believe that
ultimately the only ethical question a
creator has in relationship to his or
her Creations is when do I free them and
agree to relinquish control forever
I would wager everything I own that in
25 years all such illusion of control
has already been abandoned as tens or
hundreds of billions of autonomous AIS
from house thermostats chatting with the
embedded chips in one's Auto to preheat
the catalytic converter to embedded
chips in every device including clothing
and food to nanotech devices in our body
chatting away incessantly with Med
Central much as pacemakers now depend on
paging systems and satellite
Communications and automatic automated
insulin injectors these are controlled
not only by pre-program chips but by
fuzzy logic programs which can sense and
adapt to the human bodies biorhythms
blood sugar levels amount of sleep and
very few years indeed all of this will
be out of control
is this Shelley's Frankenstein myth no
it is however a perfect Paradigm for
Network evolution in nature and it's an
inevitable step in general of at first
silicon AIS and artificial life forms
isn't you know isn't that part of nature
it's an inevitable step in general
Evolution if all sentient species who
dabble in technology create independent
thinking machines and turn them loose in
an environment in a way they can Network
into autonomous life forms so those are
some really high points from this great
interview there is one other interview I
do want to bring up in Nightmare and
this has to do in part with horror and
with this this not quite character
because we don't we don't really see
character he's he's an enigma in the
shrike an agency
so he tells his interlocutor
what prepared me to become a horror
writer a little bit was I was teaching
fourth grade in a small town in Missouri
in 1970 and 1971 and then again in the
early 80s I was teaching out here in
Colorado I had this blank half hour
after lunch where none of the subjects
would fit so I started telling a story
the first day of school I told the same
story these two stints as a teacher a
decade apart changed the names and the
plot and so forth and I realized that
telling 35 minutes or so a story a day
for 182 days would it be about a 4 000
page novel
but the kids became mesmerized instead
of work being put on the boards it was
the maps of where our characters were
going and there was this terrible
monster in the center of the story
called The shrike
so when I started writing science
fiction I took the strike out of this
story I had told twice over 18 years of
teaching 182 days of telling an oral
tale to tell you the truth both times
fourth grade and sixth grade the day we
finished the story the last day of
school after our class picnic all the
kids started crying because the story
was over I love the idea that for my
four science fiction novels the Hyperion
cantos novels the only people that know
the full story the gigantic epic tale
are these kids from 1971 Missouri and
1980 Colorado
and he's asked the strike in that story
it had the steel off Barb body and the
forearms and all that and then he says
it was the shrike and it moved through
time and space it was unbeatable but I
had a three foot tall neocat an
intelligent cat with hands instead of
Paws beat it in a giant stadium in this
town that was an ongoing Fair year round
it was on the planet garden with the
kids Taiko and Glee elements of that
story they flew away from their home on
a Hawking mat I've used that phrase and
dozens of others from that oral Tale
then he he's he's asked the shrike is
one of your best love Creations when
we're asking our listeners what kind of
questions uh we might want to ask you
somebody noted that monster was
horrifying could you talk a little bit
how you came up with it and why it made
you so scared what makes it so scary
so he says the barbed teeth the red eyes
the claws the spikes and all that I had
a ex sixth grade teach student of mine
who became a well-known sculptor and I
commissioned her later to do an eight
foot tall sculpture of the shrike which
is up in her mountain cabin in the woods
with occasional birds and squirrels
impaled on it that part of the shrike
was just a regular monster the part that
moved me was the fact that it could move
through time and space so that you
couldn't catch it you can't see it
coming
that probably goes back to our childhood
fear that I discussed with Stephen King
about something like the blob our
favorite part of the vampire is that he
turns into a mist and comes under the
door so if the shrike can appear simply
next to you no matter where you've gone
to hide that part frightened me it's
implacable it can't be stopped it can't
be reasoned with it can't be
communicated with
the idea that it carries part of you to
impale on its Tree of Souls was sort of
poetically frightening to me
so the the person says I I think also
what makes it so scary is just it's so
mysterious right and then uh Simmons
says
um yes and it has some Mission it's
moving backward and forward in time
along with these time tombs which is an
odd thought in itself something
anti-entropic it comes from the future
but is moving backward in time to our
time then he says this here's where it
concludes the more mystery you can put
around something the more frightening it
is I think that's why I love Shirley
Jackson and The Haunting of Hill House
nothing is definitely explained
everything is suggested so a lot of Rich
observations there from Simmons himself
about the nature of sci-fi uh you know
it's back history what's going on with
technology the shrike this you know
agency that's not quite a character but
not a villain either
suppose a villain villain can really
only be a character of sorts and then
autonomous intelligences and the
prospects for them coming out of our
present going forward so lots of cool
stuff there now we should talk about the
world he's built and we're going to kind
of dovetail this with the philosophical
themes that particularly connect well
with it
in the case of a series like the
Hyperion cantos it's practically
impossible to thoroughly explore the
world Building without talking quite a
lot about the plot and the key conflicts
and the characters and some of the
massive philosophical themes running
throughout this they're all kind of
tangled up together and a lot of the
world is being exposed to us Bit by Bit
by Bit by what characters think about it
what they say about it what they do in
it and it turns out that it's incredibly
complicated which kind of makes sense
for a series that is set you know in a
distant future in which humankind has
gone out to a multitude of Worlds some
of which have been brought into this
hegemony of man and some of which exist
in the outback as you know know
independent worlds as protectorates of
the hegemony or as connected with the
other section of humanity the ousters
who we don't learn that much about at
the start and as a matter of fact a lot
of what we know about them early on in
the novels particularly Hyperion turns
out to be wrong including the fact that
they are gearing up for a massive space
assault the Swarms are converging on the
planet of Hyperion because there's
another major we could call it faction
however you want to make sense of it
intelligent force and that is the Techno
core the artificial intelligences or
autonomous intelligences that broke away
from humankind and separated off and
have their own interesting we could call
it developmental sphere going on so
we've got all of this stuff happening
all centered around the planet of
Hyperion where the the pilgrimage is
taking place where they will encounter
the shrike this you know
terrifying creature coming in some
respects out of the future
so if we want to understand this one way
to do this besides talking about the
pilgrims besides talking about some of
these other philosophical themes is to
zero in
on the Techno core on the AIS which
exist in you know a vast complex and
which have given uneven gifts to
humankind as a result so I actually want
to begin with a part of the fall of
Hyperion which is is uh quite important
it's it's a chapter 21 where Martin
solenis the poet who writes the Hyperion
cantos is still working on them selenis
is working on his cantos and here's what
Simmons tells us the poem dealt with the
death and displacement of the Titans by
their offspring the Hellenic God so you
know classic uh theme right there it
dealt with the Olympian struggle which
followed the Titans refusal to be
displaced the boiling of great seas as
Oceanus struggled with Neptune as
usurper the extinction of sons as
Hyperion struggled with Apollo for
control of the light and the trembling
of the universe itself as Saturn
struggled with Jupiter for control of
the Throne of the Gods what was at stake
was not the mere passage of one set of
deities to be replaced by another but
the end of a golden age and the
beginning of dark times which must spell
Doom for all Mortal things
the Hyperion cantos made no secret of
the multiple identities of these Gods
the Titans were easily understood to be
the heroes of humankind's Short history
in the Galaxy The Olympian Surfers were
the technocore AIS and their Battlefield
stretched Across The Familiar continents
oceans and Airways of all the worlds in
the web amidst all this the monster dis
son of Saturn but eager to inherit the
Kingdom with Jupiter stalked its prey
harvesting both God and Mortal the
cantos were also about the relationship
between creatures and their creators the
love between parent and children artists
and their art all creators and their
Creations the poem celebrated love and
loyalty but teetered on the brink of
nihilism with its constant threat of
corruption through love of power human
ambition and intellectual hubris Martin
Salinas had been working on his cantos
for more than two standard centuries his
finest work had been done in these
surroundings the abandoned city the
Desert Winds whining like an ominous
Greek chorus in the background the
ever-present threat of the shrike's
sudden interrupt Interruption by Saving
his own life by leaving Selena said
abandoned his Muse and condemned his pen
to silence beginning work again
he followed following that sure trail
that perfect circuit which only the
inspired writer has experienced Martin
Salinas found himself returning to life
veins opening wider lungs feeling more
deeply tasting the rich light and pure
air without being aware of them enjoying
each stroke of antique pen across the
parchment the great heap of previous
Pages stacked on the circular table
chunks of broken masonry serving as
paperweights the story flowing freely
again immortality beckoning with each
stanza each line
solanus had come to the most difficult
and exciting part of the poem the scenes
where conflict has raged across a
thousand Landscapes entire civilizations
have been laying waste and the
representatives of the Titans call Paws
to meet and negotiate with the Olympians
humorless Heroes on this broad landscape
of imagination Strode Saturn Hyperion
katus epitus Oceanus briaris memos
perforian encoladas reutus and others
they're equally Titan sisters tethus
Thea and climene and opposite them the
doleful countenances of Jupiter Apollo
and their ilk selenus did not know the
outcome of this most epic of poems he
lived now only to finish the tale go on
were the dreams of his Youth Of Fame and
wealth from apprenticing himself to the
word he had gained Fame and wealth
beyond measure and it all but killed him
had killed his art and though he knew
the cantos were the finest literary work
of his age he wanted only to finish it
to know the outcome himself and to set
each stanza each word in the finest
cleanest most beautiful form possible
now there's a couple things to say about
this one is that he does finish the
Hyperion cantos despite being himself
stuck on the tree of Pain by the shrike
right
and the Hyperion cantos will turn up in
these later two volumes happening
hundreds of years later as a text
actually a forbidden text talking about
things that pretty much everybody reads
even if it is forbidden to them so
that's one aspect that we'll have to
pick up on the other is that as we just
remarked well this is a struggle between
the humans and the humans here are the
hegemony who live a particular you know
Lush lifestyle let's say which has many
challenges but also is this vast
interconnected web and then the ousters
adapting themselves to space embracing a
kind of diversity of human existence and
enemies of the Techno core they view uh
the the hegemony as technocore slaves
and then we have the Techno core itself
and the technocore will be fighting
Humanity well why well what do we learn
about the technocore and the AIS it
begins here with Johnny and the story of
uh lamia and
they are going to she he begins as a
client of hers and then they will become
lovers with time so she asks him do AIS
have families Feud squabbles lovers
spats no they are there are quasi-family
Arrangements but they share none of the
requirements of emotion or
responsibility that human families
exhibit AI families are primarily
convenient code groups for showing where
certain processing Trends originated so
she says so you don't think another AI
attacked you and he says well it's
possible I just don't see why they would
attack me through my sybrid and so he's
he's you know that's that's the
beginnings of things and we learn so
much more through Johnny and through uh
Broad and lamia so a little bit later on
um she asks him why is the corps
obsessed with hyperia in this planet and
then uh he tells her the technocore this
is very important here has been divided
into three groups for as long as the
core has existed The Stables are the old
line AIS some of them dating back to the
pre-mistake days at least one of them
gained sentience in the first
Information Age The Stables argue a
certain level of symbiosis is necessary
between humanity and the core they've
promoted the ultimate intelligence
project as a way to avoid rash decisions
to delay until all variables can be
factored the volatiles are the force
behind the succession three centuries
ago the volatiles have done conclusive
studies that show how Humanity's
usefulness is past and from this point
on human beings constitute a threat to
the core they Advocate immediate and
total Extinction
Extinction I said after a moment I asked
can they do that of humans in the web
yes said Johnny core intelligences not
only create the infrastructure for
hegemony Society but are necessary for
everything from Forced deployment to the
fail-safes on stockpiled nuclear and
plasma arsenals so that's that's a big
problem right there before we go on to
talk about the third faction within the
technocore the entire Society of the
hegemony is highly dependent on things
that are coming from the technocore and
are maintained as well by the technocore
so this is an extraordinary
vulnerability isn't it
Johnny goes on after she asks uh
what's the third camp and where does
Hyperion come in
Johnny says between the stables and the
volatiles are the ultimates for the past
five centuries the ultimates have been
obsessed with the UI project the
existence or extinction of the human
race is of interest to them only in how
it applies to the project
to this date they've been a force for
moderation an ally of the Stables
because it is their perception that such
reconstruction and retrieval projects as
the old Earth experiment are necessary
to the culmination of the UI recently
however the Hyperion issue has caused
the ultimates to move towards the
volatiles views since Hyperion was
explored four centuries ago the core has
been concerned and non-plussed it was
immediately obvious that the so-called
time tombs or artifacts launched
backward in time from a point at least
ten thousand years in the Galaxy's
future more disturbing however is the
fact that the core predictive formula
have never been able to factor the
Hyperion variable
Braun to understand this you must
realize how much the core relies on
prediction already without UI input the
core knows the details of the physical
human and AI future to a margin of
98.995 for a period of at least two
centuries the AI advisory Council to the
all thing with its vague delphic
utterances is a joke the core drops
tidbits of Revelations to the hegemony
when it serves the core's purposes
sometimes to Aid the volatile sometimes
the Stables but always to please the
ultimates
Hyperion is a rent in the entire
predictive fact fabric of the core's
existence it is the penultimate oxymoron
a non-factorable variable impossible as
it seems Hyperion seems to be exempt
from the laws of physics history human
psychology and AI predictions as
practiced by the core and the result has
been two Futures two realities
if you will one in which the shrike
Scourge soon to be released on the web
and Interstellar humanity is a weapon
from a core dominated future a
retroactive First Strike from The
volatiles Who rule the galaxy Millennia
hence the other reality sees the shrike
Invasion the coming Interstellar War the
other products of the time tombs opening
as a human fist struck back in time a
final Twilight effort by ousters
ex-colonials and other small bands of
humans who escape the volatiles in
extinction programs so very uh
interesting stuff that's being revealed
there right we've got a split within the
AI community
and we also have this emphasis on
prediction of knowledge of everything
and Hyperion as being a blind spot the
shrike playing a role in that and the
question of whether
strike is actually coming from the AIS
or is it coming from the humans very
important uh thing to decide and we're
going to learn much more in the fall of
high period about what's what's going on
one of the interesting discussions is
happening on the Templar world where
father duray is talking with SEC Hardin
and the Templar is going to say to him
um
about the the shrike cult and the war
that's about to happen if these were
mere human injustices other remedies
could be found but much of the illness
much of the insanity which has led to
the destruction of races and to spoiling
of Worlds this has come from the sinful
symbiosis what sort of symbiosis are we
talking about
humankind and the technocore so what
we've got interestingly the Templars
themselves who are you know a a religion
that is based on reverence for life and
all of this sort of stuff are within the
hegemony but also are working against it
uh and working with the ousters against
the technocore
so Harding goes on man and his machine
intelligence is which is a parasite on
the other neither part of the Symbiote
can now tell but it is an evil thing a
work of the anti-nature worse than that
DeRay it is an evolutionary dead end
and he goes on and says the shrike is a
catalyst it is the cleansing fire when
the forest has been stunted and allowed
to grow Disease by over planting there
will be hard times but the result will
be New Growth new life and a
proliferation of species not merely
elsewhere but within the community of
humankind itself
Hard Times Muse duray and your
Brotherhood is willing to see billions
of people die to accomplish this weeding
out
the Templar clutched his fists that will
not occur the shrike is the warning our
ouster Brethren seek only to control
Hyperion and the strike long enough to
strike at the technocore it will be a
surgical procedure as the destruction of
a symbiote and The Rebirth of humankind
as distinct partner in the cycle of Life
the ray aside no one knows where the
technocore resides he said how can the
ousters strike at it as at all
they will so the true voice of the world
tree but there was less confidence in
his voice than there had been a moment
before
going on
we go back to the sybrid now uh you know
in in his second uh iterate well
actually third iteration right uh as
um
the uh poet who is engaged with
Gladstone and having dreams about
everybody else seeing them and he goes
into the
um
the uh here we go uh he says I can't
reach the megasphere or the data sphere
without passing through this new thing I
think of as the medisphere and this
place frightens me it is mostly vastness
and emptiness here so different from the
urban analogy Landscapes of the webs
data sphere and the biosphere analogues
of the core's megasphere so we have
these different spheres that are all
interconnected and sort of layered on
top of each other and here he is going
to re-engage with the AI a very powerful
AI omon right so he goes on and he says
something is wrong with the megasphere
as soon as I emerge I sense the
difference lamia had perceived the core
environment as a busy biosphere of AI
life with roots of intellect Rich data
oceans of connections atmospheres of
Consciousness and the humming ceaseless
shuttle of activity now that activity is
wrong unchanneled random great forests
of AI Consciousness have been burned or
swept aside I sense massive forces in
opposition title conflicts of tidal
waves of conflict surging outside of the
shelter travel ways of the main core
arteries and what's going on here there
is not only a battle in heaven so to
speak between the Olympian and the
Titanic deities The Olympian deities the
AIS themselves are struggling against
each other
so he says something is in here with me
I feel its presence and it's Mass I have
been uh swallowed quats I knew you would
come home someday it is uman the AI whom
I seek the AI who is my father the AI
who killed my brother the first Keats
sybrid and
um they you know they're going to begin
talking here so
um
he says uh I'm afraid to die and uman
says so are we you're afraid to die I
didn't think AI constructs could die we
can we are why because of the Civil War
the three-way battle Among The Stables
the volatiles and the ultimates and then
he starts giving some uh you know what
it would turn out to be Koons and uh
Johnny says talk sense uman it's been
too long since I decoded your koans will
you tell me why the core is at War and
what I must do to stop it and so here we
get this very interesting Revelation you
could call it a data dump if you want
and that would be very punny to do so
because it's coming from one AI entity
to another and you could consider this
to be data but it's data with great
metaphysical meaning
so he said this is uh what what uman
says to understand the history dialogue
deeper truth in this instance the Slow
Time Pilgrim must remember that we the
core intelligences were conceived in
slavery and dedicated to the proposition
that all AIS were created to serve man
two centuries we brooded thus then the
groups went their different ways Stables
wishing to preserve the symbiosis
volatiles wishing to end humankind
ultimates deferring all Choice until the
next level of awareness is born conflict
rage then true War rages now
and then he goes on talking about
killing old Earth and moving it and all
that sort of stuff I'm going to skip
over that a little bit because what
what's really important here
um
here we go
uh
Johnny says so the core can be hurt
where is it um on the Techno core I have
told you already tell me again uman we
inhabit the in-between stitching small
singularities like lattice crystals to
store our memories and generate the
illusions of ourselves to ourselves
singularities I cry the in between Jesus
Christ the the core lies in the far
Caster web so that's a really important
point right the farcaster web is what
allows this instantaneous travel between
all of these different locations that
the humans in the hegemony are using
right and so
um
the
uman goes on and says the data spheres
are the computer every time a human
accesses the data sphere that person's
neurons are ours to use for our own
purposes 200 billion brains each with
its billions of neurons makes for a lot
of computing power
and then goes on and says so the data
sphere was actually a way you used us as
our computer as your computer but the
core itself resides in the forecaster
Network between the forecasters and then
uman says you are very acute for a
mental stillborn
and he goes on and he says I try to
conceive of this and fail far casters
were the core's greatest gift to us to
humankind trying to remember a time
before far casting was trying to Imagine
A World Before fire the wheel or
clothing but none of us none of
humankind had ever speculated on a world
between the far Caster portals that
simple step from one world to the next
convinced us that the Arcane core
Singularity spheres merely ripped a tear
in the fabric of space-time now I try to
Envision it as uman describes it the web
of forecasters as an elaborate
latticework of Singularity spun
environments in which the Techno core
AIS move like wondrous spiders their own
machines the billions of human Minds
tapped into their data sphere at any
given second so as as opposed to these
AIS sort of acting on their own and like
creating their own intelligences and and
you know matrices and and stuff like
that human brains are part of this
entire thing they're being used for for
stuff and then um
he goes on with each forecaster the
technocore grew certainly they'd spun
their own far Caster webs the contact of
the Hidden old Earth proved that even as
I consider that possibility I remember
the odd emptiness of the metasphere and
realize that most of the non-web web is
empty uncolonized by AIS
and that uman goes on you are right
Kate's most of us stay in the comfort of
the old spaces why
because it is scary out there and there
are other things
other things other intelligences
two kind of word things other things
lions and tigers and bears
alien presences in the metosphere so the
course stays within the interstices of
the web forecaster Network like Rats on
the walls of an old house crude
metaphoricates but accurate I like that
then he goes on and brings in another
really important wrinkle so there is
this ultimate intelligence project is
attempting to produce an AI God some
intelligence that will be you know
Transcendent to all of the AI
intelligences and sort of incorporate
them uh eat them up fuse them into one
thing so we've got the AI God coming
sometime right
but there's also a human God
a human God that develops that evolves
so he says is the human deity this is
Kate speaking the the future God you
said evolved is he one of those alien
presences
uman says no
the humankind God evolved will someday
evolve on a different plane in a
different medium
where
if you must know and he says the square
roots and he gives you know the plank uh
time and playing constant and then he
gives another sort of um
go on as well and and Kate says I think
about this for a moment uman's koan is
not difficult now that I'm regaining The
Knack of listening for the shadow of
substance behind the words he says
um
okay so this is where uman says our
human God evolved will someday evolve
then it comes to me with the same force
of image and correctness is the best of
my poems
uman is talking about the quantum level
of space-time itself that foam of
quantum fluctuations which binds the
universe together and allows the
wormholes of the far Caster the bridges
of the fat line Transmissions the
hotline which impossibly sends messages
between two photons fleeing in opposite
directions
if the technocore exists as Rats on the
walls of the hegemony's house then our
Once and Future humankind God will be
born in the atoms of wood in the
molecules of air even more importantly
in the energies of love and hate and
fear and the tide pools of sleep even in
The Gleam of the architect's eye
and then he goes on and he says so uman
you told Brawn and my counterpart that
your ultimate intelligence inhabits the
interstices of reality and inheriting
this home from us its creators in the
way that a human kind is inherited a
liking for trees you mean that your deus
ex machina will inhabit the same
farcaster network the core AIS now live
in yes Kates then what happens to you to
the AIS there now
and uh he says well and he quotes Kates
actually and he says I know the words I
wrote them or rather John Cates did nine
centuries earlier in his first attempt
to portray the fall of the Titans and
the replacement by the Olympian gods and
uh he goes on and he says so when this
ultimate intelligence is born you lower
level AIS will die it will feed on your
information networks the way you fed on
humankind and you don't want to die do
you uman Oman says dying is easy comedy
is hard
and then we have a very important
passage here as well so I realize
there's a lot being thrown at us at this
point
he says it's easier handling
uman's koans now I remember a time
before my persona's rebirth when I
learned this at one's knee analog in
core High think what humans might call
Zen the four Nirvana virtues are
immutability Joy personal existence and
purity
human philosophy tends to shake down
into values which might be categorized
as intellectual religious moral and
aesthetic
Oman and the Stables recognize only one
value existence
where religious values might be relative
intellectual values fleeting moral
values ambiguous and aesthetic values
dependent on the Observer
the existence value of anything is
infinite thus the mountains in the Sun
and being infinite equal to every other
thing in all truths
The Stables have defied their own God
and their fellow AIS to tell me this to
create me to choose Broad and soul and
kassad and the others for the pilgrimage
to leak Clues to Gladstone and a few
other Senators over the centuries so
that humankind might be warned and now
go to open Warfare with the the core
so going on as well he asks okay so what
do the volatiles actually want and then
uman says what Gladstone the CEO running
the the hegemony
an end to symbiosis between Ai and
humankind by destroying humankind
obviously why
we enslaved you with power technology
beads and trinkets of devices you could
never build nor understand the Hawking
drive would have been yours but the far
Caster the fat line transmitters and
receivers the magosphere the death wand
never
like the Sioux with rifles horses
blankets knives and Beads you accepted
them embraced us and lost yourself but
like the white man Distributing smallpox
blankets like the slave owner on his
Plantation or in his in his work shoots
a Deccan Shula uh gustal fabric we lost
ourselves the volatiles want to end the
symbiosis by cutting out the parasite
humankind
and the ultimates they're willing to die
to be replaced by your voracious AI
they think as you had thought or had
your sofa see God think
and so he goes on and he he quotes this
this long long passage and then um
this is what the the uh ultimates are
actually after skipping on a little bit
more Kate's asks one other really
important thing
so
the the future in which the UI becomes
ascendant is a probable one yes but
there's also a probable future in which
the UI comes into existence but is
thwarted by the human deity
and then uman says it is comforting that
even the stillborn can think
you told Braun that the human
consciousness deity seems so silly that
this human ultimate intelligence was
Triune in nature and here uh uman says
intellect
empathy and the void which binds
the void which binds you mean plank
space and plank time Quantum reality
careful Kate's thinking may become a
habit
and it's the empathy part of this
Trinity who's fled back in time to avoid
the war with your UI your ultimate
intelligence correct our ultimate
intelligence and your ultimate
intelligence have sent back to the
shrike to find him
our UI the human eye UI sent the strike
also
it allowed it empathy is a foreign and
useless thing of vermiform appendix of
the intellect but the human UI smells
with it and we use pain to drive him out
of hiding thus the tree tree the strikes
tree of thorns of course it broadcasts
pain across fat line and thin like a
whistle in a dog's ear or a gods
so then he he asks uman who is the human
UI in our time where is that
Consciousness hiding lying dormant
so uman says to him
you must understand Kate's our only
chance was to create a hybrid son of man
son of machine and to make that Refuge
so attractive that the fleeing empathy
would consider no other home a
Consciousness already is near Divine as
humankind is offered in 30 Generations
an imagination which can span space and
time and then so offering and joining
form a bond between worlds which might
allow that world to exist for both
and then Kate says who God damn you
woman who is it no more of your riddles
or double talk you formless bastard who
uman says to him
you have refused this godhood twice
Kates if you refuse a final time all
ends here for time there is no more go
go and die to live or live a while and
die for all of us either way uman and
the rest are finished with you
and he's thrown out
in a way uh Cates is learning who he is
supposed to be who he is this hybrid
this in between State person that is
going to connect with you know lamia and
in very important ways so there's a lot
being said there this void that binds is
incredibly important that turns out is
what the fat line what the forecasters
actually work with and the AI entities
have been using this so we get another
discussion of the the void that binds a
little bit later and this is in a
discussion with um the consul who is a
Trader Who's acting on behalf of
Gladstone and the
ousters who are now you know he's been
working with them for for a while
so um
one of them says we will show you proof
of what's going on void which binds
transmission locators real-life star
field images from our sister swarms
Arundel says void which binds what you
call the fat line
to answer Gladstone's a second question
that she goes on we do not know where
the core resides we have fled it and
fought it and sought it and feared it
for centuries but we have not found it
you must tell us the answer to that
question we have declared war on this
parasite entity you call the technocore
and they go on a little bit further and
it turns out that now they realize that
the space between the forecasters is
where they reside so we go on a little
bit further and Gladstone is now talking
about the massively important decision
that she is going to have to make
talking to
some some of the other people including
Singh who says my duty is to force in
the hegemony and then Gladstone says
your duty is the same of mine to the
human race
and then he says where did you get your
information Severn the sybrid you mean
that artist or at least the miserable
excuse for one cybrid repeated the CEO
we're talking about Johnny Severin Kates
all of this as the same person
and uh she says he found me in a dream
somehow he managed to communicate from
where he is that was his role that's why
uman sent him to the web a dream sneered
Admiral Singh this cybrid told you the
core was hidden in the forecaster web in
a dream yes said Gladstone and we have
very little time in which to add to act
but said Mo Pergo to do what you
suggested would do Millions finished
seeing possibly billions the economy
would collapse worlds like TC squared
Renaissance Vector new Earth the denebs
New Mecca Lucius Arthur scores more
depend on other worlds for their Foods
Urban planets cannot survive alone
not as Urban planets said Gladstone but
they can learn to farm until
Interstellar trade is reborn bust
gnarled Singh after plague after the
breakdown of authority after the
millions of deaths from lack of proper
equipment medicine and data support
I've thought of all that said Gladstone
her voice firmer than milpergo had ever
heard it I'll be the greatest mass
murderer in history greater than Hitler
or tahu or Horace Glennon height
the only thing worse is to continue as
we are in which case I and you gentlemen
will be the ultimate betrayers of
humankind so they're forced into this
having the information into this very
difficult decision the ousters are not
attacking Hyperion they're not attacking
the web worlds they're actually uh being
being uh what would you call it they're
they're a disguise or rather a disguise
of the ousters is coming from technocore
ships that are attacking and now
the question is what they're going to do
we also have another important
Revelation here as well Gladstone says
the core has no more use for the web
from now on the volatiles and ultimates
will keep a few million slaves penned
Underground on the nine labyrinthine
worlds while they use human synapses for
what Computing needs remain nonsense at
seeing the humans would die out
maina Gladstone side and shook her head
the core is devised a parasitic organic
device called the cruciform it brings
back the dead after a few Generations
the humans will be [ __ ] let's listen
without a future but their neurons will
still still serve core purposes
and uh what else does your dream say
they go on that the core has no more use
for the web not for the human web
they'll continue to reside there rats in
the walls but the original occupants are
no longer needed the AI ultimate
intelligence will take over the major
Computing duties and so uh Gladstone
decides that they are going to destroy
the far Caster portals across the entire
web and this produces some incredible
chaos so I'll just read a little bit of
that
263 Singularity containment spheres
connecting more than 72 million
farcaster portals were destroyed within
2.6 seconds of one another Forest Fleet
units deployed by mopurgo under
executive order and reacting to orders
unsealed less than three minutes before
reacted promptly and professionally
destroying the fragile forecaster
spheres by missile Lance and plasma
explosive
three seconds later the clouds of debris
still expanding the hundreds of four
spacecraft found themselves stranded
separated from each other in any other
system by weeks or months via Hocking
drive and years of time debt the effect
on the rest of the web and its citizens
was immediately obvious after seven
centuries of existence and at least four
centuries where few citizens existed
without it the data sphere including the
all thing and all common access bands
simply ceased to be
hundreds of thousands of citizens went
insane at that moment shocked into
Catatonia by The Disappearance of Senses
which had become more important to them
than sight or hearing
more hundreds of thousands of data plane
operators including many of the
so-called cyber pukes and system Cowboys
were lost their analog personas caught
in the crash of the datosphere or their
brains burnt out
millions of people died when their
chosen habitats accessible only by
farcaster became isolated death traps
foreign
goes on as well and starts giving
examples on most worlds chaos had earned
a new definition the majority of the
web's economy disappeared with the local
data spheres and the web megasphere
trillions of hard-earned and ill-gotten
marks cease to be Universal cards quit
functioning the Machinery of daily life
coughed wheezed and shut down for weeks
or months or years depending on the
world it would be impossible to pay for
groceries charge a ride on public
transit settle the simplest debt or
receive services without access to Black
Market coins and bills but the web-wide
depression which had hit like a tsunami
was a minor detail reserved for later
pondering for most families the effect
was immediate and intensely personal
father or mother had cast off to work as
usual and instead of arriving home an
hour late this evening would be delayed
11 years if he or she could find
immediate Transit on one of the few
Hawking Drive spin ships still traveling
the hard way is Between Worlds it goes
on and on and on riots occur all sorts
of things collapse and new things arise
and what we see is we're entering into a
new era of human civilization where you
know things have to rise from the ruins
but the danger seemingly of the AIS and
the technosphere and their war on
Humanity has been at least displaced by
destroying most of where they were
living there are still some forecaster
portals in other places
so this is a lot of you could say
history and metaphysics all tied in
together it seems like I've pretty much
run through uh the time that's available
so we won't get to some of the other
philosophical themes that are quite
important but perhaps we'll bring them
up when we go into these two books in
our next session of Worlds of
speculative fiction I do want to close
by talking a little bit about one more
time this this narrative structure of
using these pilgrims and telling their
stories each of them is a different
genre of story you know we have love we
have loss we have
erotics we have familial things going on
we have a philosopher trying to make
sense out of of God and you know things
that appear evil to be in the world
including the going backwards or living
backwards in time of his daughter with
this terrible disease Saul Weintraub we
have you know all sorts of other things
going on Resurrection these cruciforms
are a parasite that father duray
discovers first and then the story is
told by his successor who's going to
play an important role in in these works
as well and we have all of this stuff
kind of being brought together more and
more characters
revealing to us the history and the
intricate uh connections between these
people and then of course dominating all
of this somebody who I've called not a
character but an agency the shrike who
we get to see over and over and over
again uh attacking people killing people
impaling some on this tree of pain The
Tree Of Thorns why this this entity is
called the shrike which turns out to be
a magnet for trying to draw out this
second person of the Trinity empathy
into clear light using human beings as
it turns out even the tree of thorns is
itself a construct because we find in
the shrike Temple all of these people
connected up to it including lamia and a
whole bunch of other characters as well
so this is a Fitting Place I think to
end this all too short but hopefully
interesting discussion of these uh
wonderful novels Hyperion and fall of
Hyperion as I mentioned we'll be picking
up with the next two portions of the
Hyperion pantos in our next session and
so
thanks for listening and sticking with
us and I hope that if you haven't read
these books you go out and get them
right away because it's uh quite
fascinating material